there are so many great ways to help out
our community and we know everyone out
there has such a big heart Salvation
Army's red cattle campaign of course
that's a holiday tradition it gives your
realm but it needs volunteers in order
to make the thing go helping those in
need Candace Charles is joining us live
this morning from the Salvation Army
with that story Candace good morning to
you
good morning YouTube good morning folks
I got to tell you that I'm already
liking
ringing this Bell it really does remind
me of holiday memories and you guys can
get in on this memory as well by being a
volunteer as we mentioned it's a little
low in the valley this year I'm joined
by Captain Orion virtual thank you so
much for joining us this morning tell us
a little bit how you make it easier for
folks to become volunteers as well well
you know really uh during this time of
year we we just require a smile there
you go and a willingness to bring that
holiday cheer to people same simple
enough yeah it really is whether it be
by yourself with your family maybe your
furry little friend or maybe some
co-workers you want to get a little
friendly competition in I always like
that and you guys do try to make it
simple as well by putting people closest
to their homes their jobs everything
right absolutely because whatever we can
do to help you helps us there's a
community effort so definitely we we'd
love to make it simple for you because
it helps us as well yes absolutely it's
one of your biggest campaign to help all
year round but you do have a couple of
drives if you can't volunteer if you
don't have the cash to donate you can do
other things right tell us about those
drives absolutely we're trying to help
at least a thousand families this
Christmas so by doing donating a toy you
can bring it to any of our locations you
can also even bring a brand new coat to
Crate and Barrel they're helping us
collect coats because it is a cool time
of year that's for sure uh and and if
you go online to you know the Salvation
Army
southernnevada.org there's other ways in
which you can help too
I hear you can also get something back
for donating yes yes so glittering
lights which is awesome uh we have
little coupons five dollars off if you
can give anything to help us we'd love
to encourage you by giving you a little
of that so you can go and see those
twinkling lights I love it thank you so
much Captain Ryan Rachel for all that
you do in the community and for joining
us this morning all of those details of
course you guys are on our website
newsnow.com now I got the number for you
if you'd like to volunteer at
702-870-4430 or you can donate at Red
kettles
5155. all right guys of course again I
got those details for you on the website
newsnow.com for now live from Salvation
Army I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now